herzlich willkommen zurück auf meinem
kanal willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute zeige ich euch wie ihr ganz
kräftige gesunde vitale tomaten
pflänzchen selber vorziehen könnte ich
weiß nicht ob ihr das kennt
tomatenpflanzen werden wenn sie unter
schlechten bedingungen vorgezogen werden
ganz schnell dünnen langgezogen gelb und
schwächlich und um das zu verhindern
gilt es einige sachen zu beachten und
wie das genau funktioniert mit der
tomaten anzucht das zeige ich euch
schritt für schritt in diesem video so
dass ihr richtig kräftige und vitale
tomaten in eurem gartenpflanzen könnt
[Musik]
wann sollte man denn mit der tomaten
anzucht anfangen das kommt immer ein
bisschen darauf an wo man die tomaten
später pflanzen möchte tomaten die ins
gewächshaus kommen wenn schon ein
bisschen früher vorgezogen werden als
die tomaten die dann ins freiland
gepflanzt werden im freiland kann man
erst ab mitte mai pflanzen weil dann die
eisheiligen vorbei sind weil dann keine
früchte mehr drohen im gewächshaus kann
man das teilweise schon ein paar wochen
frühjahr machen deswegen fange ich mit
der vor anzucht für die gewächshaus
tomaten ende februar an und mit der
anzucht für die freiland tomaten erst
mitte märz das ist ganz wichtig ich sehe
dass immer wieder dass ganz viele leute
schon im januar anfangen ihre tomaten zu
sehen gerade auf facebook das sieht man
dann immer die ganzen post und da werde
ich immer so aber war hatte doch noch
ein bisschen ich kann das so gut
nachvollziehen dass man soviel garten
vorfreude in sich hat dass man unbedingt
mit den ersten ausfahrten anfangen
möchte aber diese tomaten die müssen
dann so lange drinnen ausharren bis sie
endlich nach draußen gepflanzt werden
können das ist sinnvoller ist ein
bisschen zu warten und die tomaten
wirklich erst dann vorzuziehen wenn es
soweit ist sprich ende februar oder
mitte märz je nachdem ob sie ins
gewächshaus oder ins freiland kommen
weil den tomatenpflanzen denen wird es
auf dauer viel zu enge lehnt töpfchen
wenn die so lange im haus warten müssen
bis sie dann endlich in die beete waren
dann können deswegen haltet euch messe
an die vorgesehenen auszeit punkte dass
es immer sinnvoller ich selber indem sie
ja nachdem maria ton kalender aus dem
demeter kalender dann kann ich euch
gerne nochmal hier unter dem video
verlinken
deswegen acht ich bei der aussaat auch
immer darauf dass ich die tomaten
möglichst an einem frucht tag aussehen
damit sie später auf sie gerichtet
welche anzuchterde sollte man jetzt für
tomaten verwenden
ich verwende entweder gekaufte
anzuchterde dachte ich immer darauf dass
die bio und tor frei ist aber viel
lieber gerade für stark ch die tomaten
ja sind verwende ich schlichtweg gut
gereiften g siebten kompost dagegen
einige ist wahrscheinlich ein kompost
kann man doch nicht
aussehen aber doch das kann man ich
mache das seit jahren so und ich habe
viel bessere erfahrungen gemacht die
tomaten direkt in kompost aus zu sehen
also wir nicht antrifft erde nehme die
ja sehr nährstoffarm ist deswegen so
lange ich genug kompost habe ist das
immer meine erste wahl immer bevor die
tomaten samen in die erde kommen habe
ich aber noch einen kleinen geheimtipp
für euch und zwar keine ich tomaten
immer vor in so kleinen siebten die
sammle ich immer und dann nämlich
küchenpapier feuchte das an verteilt
darauf die samen einer sorte klappt das
zusammen und packt das hier in dieses
subtypen weil so können die samen vor
keimen deshalb die vorteile dass die
keinem rate sehr viel besser ist das
heißt von den samen die man sät gehen
sehr viel mehr samen auf und das geht
sehr viel schneller und deswegen
betrifft ich die dann immer das ist hier
die sorte c zero und sehr dann immer
meine samen in diesen tütchen aus und
lasst die sofort heim weil tomaten ja so
wärme bedürftig sind ist es wichtig dass
die keine temperatur 20 bis 24 grad
beträgt die wollen es also fühlen
gemütlich warm haben beim keimen
deswegen lege ich die immer unter die
heizung können die dann ein paar tage
vor keinen muss man regelmäßig
nachschauen ob sich die samen schon
entwickelt haben wenn da so kleine
spitzen aus den samen rausschauen dann
ist es zeit dass die in die erde
umziehen wenn du lust hast das projekt
gemüsegarten in diesem jahr mal so
richtig anzugehen richtig durchzustarten
in deinem garten dann kommen gerne in
meinem gemüsegarten bootcamp das ist
mein kostenlose video mini kurs mit dem
ich dir zeige vom beete anlegen über das
aussehen bis hin zu meinen besten zeit
spartipps im hochsommer was du alles
beachten muss um einen richtig
erfolgreichen ertragreichen
pflegeleichten und produktiven
gemüsegarten zu haben da kannst du dich
gern kostenlos für anmelden der legt ist
unten in der video beschreibung ich
freue mich auf jeden fall wenn du damit
dabei will ist das auch so eine ganz
tolle gemeinschaft entstanden aus ganz
vielen gartenfreunden die sich immer
gegenseitig weiterhelfen ist auf jeden
fall eine ganz tolle sache aber kommen
wir zurück zu unseren tomaten samen
sobald die geheim
sind und sich da die ersten keine
spitzen zeigen ist es zeit die
auszusehen und das mache ich am anfang
immer in einen größeren topf ich nehme
mir ungefähr so einem großen topf für
den mit reifem kompost wie eben schon
erklärt und dann sehe ich alle ein
zentimeter 1 cm tief ein samenkorn und
befürchte dass gut und stelle das wieder
unter die heizung so dass weiterhin eine
temperatur von ungefähr 20 bis 24 grad
herrscht so dass die samen mit keimen
können und sobald die ersten pflanzen
aufgegangen sind sollten die dann an
einen ort umziehen an dem es ungefähr 16
bis 18 grad hat danach würden dies
nämlich eher ein bisschen kühler das ist
wichtig damit die pflanzen schön kräftig
und getrunken werden es ist natürlich
ganz wichtig dass man die erde immer
feucht hält das versteht sich
wahrscheinlich von selber also die erde
darf nie austrocknen
weil sonst können da auch keine samen
mehr aufgehen also sache ist noch ganz
wichtig beim auszählen und das vergesse
ich auch jedes mal wieder nämlich dass
man die sorten beschriftet es ist so
schade wenn man tomaten felsigen
vorzieht und am ende nicht mehr weiß was
das für eine sorte war so dass man nicht
mehr weiß
die hat mir besonders gut geschmeckt und
die hat mir nicht so gut geschmeckt
deswegen ist es immer immer immer
sinnvoll wenn man da kleine schildchen
dran macht und die sorte gleich mit
drauf schreibt so dass man später im
garten dann auch weiß welche sorten
diejenigen sind die besonders lecker
sind die besonders ertragreich sind und
welche so hat man es ist ja vielleicht
nicht unbedingt nochmal anbauen muss was
aber noch viel wichtiger ist als die
temperatur ist das licht dass es
wirklich das aller aller aller
wichtigste wenn man tomatenpflanzen
selber vorziehen möchte
die brauchen super viel licht und zwar
16 stunden am tag und das schafft eine
normale fensterbank einfach nicht und
das ist wahrscheinlich auch der grund
warum wenn du schon mal schwächliche
tomatenpflanzen hat ist warum die so
lang gezogen sind und so schwächlich und
so leicht umknicken das liegt ganz oft
daran dass sie zu wenig licht haben
deswegen verwende ich led pflanzen
lichter das sind so led paneele die
leuchten in allen möglichen grellen
farben die pflanzen leben brauchen dich
besteht ja aus unterschiedlichen farben
und die pflanzen brauchen
unterschiedliche farben um zb ihre
blätter gut zu entwickeln oder ihre
wurzeln und diesel
die paneele die sind so ausgelegt dass
es optimal ist um jungpflanzen
vorzuziehen die led paneele die habe ich
einfach mit einer zeitschaltuhr so
eingestellt dass sie von 6 bis 22 uhr
leuchten also 16 stunden am tag und das
ist wirklich der allerwichtigste faktor
warum gemüsepflanzen ich es geht nicht
nur um tomaten sondern um alle gemüse
pflanzen die man zuhause vorziehen
möchte nicht gelegen dass man versucht
uns an der fensterbank irgendwie
hinzukriegen weil die meisten fenster
haben einfach nicht genug licht als dass
man den pflanzen da irgendwie gerecht
werden könnte ich kann euch gerne die
led paneele unter dem video verlinken
die ich da verwende habt ihr auch schon
gemüse vorgezogen seid ihr auch schon
fleißig am aussehen und pikieren ja
erzählt mir das gerne mal unten in den
kommentaren ich finde das immer ganz
nett damit euch zu plaudern und übrigens
falls ihr das nicht wusstet ich bin
immer wenn ein video online geht also
samstags um 10 für eine stunde online
und beantworte alle kommentare also so
weit ich komme also wenn ihr konkrete
fragen habt oder so dann kommt gerne
samstags um 10 unter das neue video und
da kann ich euch dann ganz schnell
weiterhelfen da bin ich immer bis 11 uhr
online wenn die tomaten pflänzchen auf
gegangen sind dann haben wir ja erst mal
zwei blätter die ein bisschen anders
aussehen als die an echten tomaten
blätter das sind die keimblätter und
danach nach diesem ersten blatt park
entwickeln sich die richtigen ersten
blätter und sobald eine tomaten
flamschen so groß sind gilt es dass sie
von ihrem großen töpfchen in eigene
töpfe umziehen die brauchen dann nämlich
mehr platz und dann geht es an das
sogenannte peak ihnen das ist ganz
wichtig dass man das mit tomaten macht
weil wie das sehr gerne haben die können
ja auch nicht in so einem überfüllten
töpfchen können die überhaupt nicht groß
werden also die brauchen wirklich einen
großen topf der sollte einen durchmesser
von 11 bis 13 zentimetern haben größer
ist natürlich immer besser und den für
dich auch wieder mit gut gereifte und
gesiebt im kompost und da hatte ich die
pflanzen so rein ist nur noch die
blätter zu sehen sind also der ganze
stängel sollte eingepflanzt werden und
mit erde bedeckt werden bis zu den
untersten blättern das ist gut weil sich
dann noch mehr wurzeln bilden und weil
die pflänzchen
stabiler stehen und noch ein tipp wenn
du deine tomaten peak hier ist dann halt
wie immer an den blättern festigen
bilden das nämlich überhaupt nicht wenn
man sie am stängel quetscht also immer
egal ob es tomaten sind oder andere
gemüse immer an den blättern halten wenn
du die um top ist und wenn wir schon mal
dabei sind es hier noch ein tipp wenn
sich bei einzelnen tomaten plätzchen die
keimblätter nicht richtig ausbreiten
also die allererste blätter wenn die
irgendwie verkrüppelt sind oder immer
noch ein bisschen eingeklappt dann
reicht diese pflänzchen raus ich weil es
ist tut weh
kleine potenzierung auszureißen ich
mache das auch nicht gerne aber das sind
die pflanzen die später einen sehr
schlechten ertrag abwerfen würden und
immer hinter den anderen hinterher
hinken würden deswegen kann man da schon
so ein bisschen selektieren und die
fersen von vornherein rausreißen weil da
lohnt es sich nicht die ganze arbeit
reinzustecken die man beim vorziehen
wenn pflanzen beim anbau von tomaten er
aufbringen muss wenn deine fläschchen
dann zwei drei wochen als sind dann wird
es zeit für die erste dünnere gabe ich
mache das immer über das gießwasser da
nehme ich biologischen flüssigdünger
also mit einem bio siegel drauf das ist
immer ganz wichtig dass man da wirklich
darauf achtet dass ein bio siegel drauf
ist weil ganz viele dünger für machen
irgendwie of bio aber die sind überhaupt
nicht bio das ist die reinste chemie
pampe deswegen achte ich da immer drauf
bisher hinten auf der flasche meistens
darauf dass da wirklich ein bio siegel
drauf ist für die jungpflanzen anzucht
verdünne ich den flüssigdünger aber noch
sehr stark also doppelt so stark wie auf
der packung angegeben ist so viel dünger
brauchen die pflanzen nämlich am anfang
gar nicht es ist wichtig dass sie so
einen kleinen stickstoff schub bekommen
in dem alter also im alter von zwei bis
drei wochen auch im kompost ist sehr
viel weniger stickstoff enthalten als
die meisten leute denken
deswegen ist es wichtig dass man diese
dinger gabe gibt aber eben sehr sehr
stark verdünnt am anfang noch den bio
dünger gibst du also in der gießwasser
und dann gehst du deine tomaten damit
ganz normal ist immer am schlauesten
wieso zu gießen dass das wasser in der
unterlage steht also nicht oben in den
topf fließen sondern in die unterlage in
der deine ganzen töpfchen stehen so dass
das wasser sich hoch in den topf sagen
kann das ist die beste art jungpflanzen
zu gießen und so kannst du dir auch über
das gießwasser dünnen wenn es soweit ist
eigentlich euch natürlich wie man die
tomaten im garten pflanzen oder im
gewächshaus ich hab noch ganz viele
andere tomaten videos geplant für dieses
jahr also abonniert gerne den kanal und
drückt auch die glocke damit sie
informiert werden sobald das nächste
video erscheint vergesst nicht euch für
das bootcamp anzumelden der link ist wie
gesagt unten in der video beschreibung
da drüben zeige ich euch meine fünf
allerliebsten tomaten sollten wenn die
da noch inspiration braucht schaut gerne
mal vorbei da unten ist auch noch ein
spannendes video vielleicht sehen wir
uns ja gleich da oder da wieder biss
dann tschüss